Psychotherapy is a personal process for many people. What works for me may not work for you. But in other health care settings, there is research that has offered some guidance to people looking for the right therapist and the right treatment. In this episode, we talk with psychologist and researcher, Bruce Wampold, about how to make psychotherapy effective and long-lasting. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology.
对很多人来说，心理治疗是一个非常个人的过程。对我有用的方法可能对你并不适用。但在其他医疗保健领域中，有一些研究为寻找合适治疗师和合适疗法的人提供了一些指导。在本期节目中，我们邀请了心理学家兼研究员布鲁斯·万波德（Bruce Wampold），探讨如何让心理治疗变得有效且持久。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），欢迎收听《心理学热线》。
Bruce Wampold is the Patricia L. Walit Professor of Counseling Psychology at the University of Wisconsin-Madison. He's also director of the Research Institute at Modembad Psychiatric Center in Norway. He served on the American Psychological Association's Presidential Task Force on Evidence-Based Practice in Psychology, and his research on psychotherapy and methodology has been published in several APA journals, including Psychological Bulletin, American Psychologist, and the Journal of Consulting and Clinical Psychology. He is author of the book The Great Psychotherapy Debate, which is a synthesis of empirical
布鲁斯·万波德是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的帕特里夏·L·瓦利特咨询心理学教授。他还是挪威莫登巴德精神病学中心研究所的主任。他曾任美国心理学会（APA）循证心理实践总统工作组委员，他对心理治疗和方法论的研究发表在多本APA期刊上，包括《心理学公报》、《美国心理学家》以及《咨询与临床心理学杂志》。他是《伟大的心理治疗之争》一书的作者，该书综合了对心理治疗的实证
research on psychotherapy and provides a model for understanding how psychotherapy works. Welcome, Dr. Wampold. Thank you. Psychotherapy is tremendously effective for many people, but is it correct to say that psychotherapy works differently for different people? Well, there's many approaches to psychotherapy, and many people come with different kinds of problems, different styles. So yes, it does work differently for different people, but in the core, it's probably more similar than it is different. So if I were a client seeking therapy, how would I know I'm getting the best treatment? And like you said, I know we're all different, we all have our different issues, but there's got to be a way to determine what's working for you.
心理治疗研究，并为理解心理治疗的工作原理提供了一个模型。欢迎您，万波德博士。谢谢。心理治疗对许多人来说非常有效，但说心理治疗对不同的人起作用的方式不同，这种说法对吗？嗯，心理治疗有很多种方法，许多人带着各种各样的问题和不同的风格来求助。所以是的，它对不同的人确实起作用的方式不同，但从核心来看，其相似之处可能大于不同之处。那么，如果我是一个寻求治疗的来访者，我怎么知道自己正在接受最好的治疗呢？就像您说的，我知道我们各不相同，我们都有各自的问题，但一定有一种方法可以确定什么对你有效。
Well, psychotherapy is a very personal process. You have a therapist and delivering a particular kind of treatment. The most important thing is that you have faith in the therapist and the treatment method the therapist is using with you. And this is something you should discuss with your therapist. So if you feel like you're not making progress and most patients make relatively significant progress in the first five or six sessions, then you should discuss that with your therapist and discuss the progress you're making and how therapy is progressing. So what you're saying, every therapist is different and has their own style, but what qualities do all effective therapists have? You know, and how can a patient select some of those qualities to treat their specific issues?
嗯，心理治疗是一个非常个人的过程。你有一位治疗师，并且他正在提供某种特定的治疗。最重要的是，你对治疗师以及治疗师正在对你使用的治疗方法有信心。这是你应该与治疗师讨论的事情。如果你觉得没有取得进展——大多数患者在前五到六次会话中会取得相对显着的进展——那么你应该与治疗师讨论这个问题，并讨论你正在取得的进展以及治疗的进展情况。所以您的意思是，每个治疗师都不同，都有自己的风格，但所有高效的治疗师都具备哪些特质呢？你知道，患者又该如何选择其中某些特质来治疗他们的具体问题呢？
Well, it's true. Therapists have a lot of different styles, and they're successful therapists who are very different than others who are also successful. But there is a common core we know now of characteristics and actions of effective therapists. Effective therapists have a very sophisticated set of interpersonal skills that are focused on helping the patient. Successful therapists or effective therapists are able to form a working relationship with a variety of patients. And effective therapists seem to be those who are reflective and practiced deliberately to get better. So for the patient, it's really difficult to assist. whether the therapist has these qualities.
嗯，确实如此。治疗师有许多不同的风格，有些非常成功的治疗师与其他同样成功的治疗师截然不同。但我们现在知道，高效的治疗师拥有一个共同的核心，即他们的特征和行动。高效的治疗师具备一套高度复杂的、专注于帮助患者的人际交往技能。成功的治疗师或高效的治疗师能够与各种患者建立工作关系。而且，高效的治疗师似乎往往是那些具有反思能力并刻意练习以不断进步的人。因此，对于患者来说，其实很难去评估
But again, this is something that should be discussed with the therapist in terms of do you feel like you're making adequate progress in the therapeutic endeavor. How long should that progress take? Are we talking weeks, months, years? Well, it really depends on the problem people bring. Many problems that people bring to therapy are really amenable to a treatment of five or six. or 10 sessions make significant progress. Therapy is something that you don't just do once in life and you're cured.
治疗师是否具备这些特质。但同样，这也是应该与治疗师讨论的事情，比如你是否觉得自己在治疗工作中取得了足够的进展。这种进展应该持续多久？我们说的是几周、几个月还是几年？嗯，这 realmente（确实）取决于人们带来的问题。许多人带到治疗中来的问题实际上非常适合五、六次或十次的治疗，并能取得显着的进展。治疗并不是你一生中只做一次就能彻底治愈的。
You might feel quite satisfied for several years, and then there's another stressor in your life or something happens and you want to go back, and that's perfectly ordinarily. There are some disorders, severe disorders, in which it's more like a chronic disease like diabetes, and you might require more intensive care for longer periods of time. Is this something you should be discussing with your therapist at the start of your treatment? How long should you be going before you see some benefits?
你可能会在好几年里感到相当满意，然后生活中出现了另一个压力源或者发生了什么事情，你想再回去寻求帮助，这完全是很平常的。有些病症，也就是严重的病症，更像是糖尿病这样的慢性病，你可能需要更长时间的更密集的护理。这是不是应该在治疗开始时就与治疗师讨论的问题？在你看到一些效果之前，你应该接受多久的治疗？
Absolutely. This is something the therapist should assess and discuss with you and you should get an idea about what is the conditions of the therapy, both in terms of its length, but the activities you're going to do, your prognosis and these kinds of things. We know now that therapy can be as effective as medication for some of these disorders. You know, clinical trials have been done on this. Yet many doctors prescribe psychotropic medications without even recommending therapy.
绝对是的。这是治疗师应该评估并与你讨论的事情，你应该对治疗的条件有一个大致的了解，包括治疗的时长、你要进行的活动、你的预后以及诸如此类的事情。我们现在知道，对于其中一些病症，心理治疗可以和药物治疗一样有效。你知道，这方面的临床试验已经做过了。然而，许多医生甚至在不推荐心理治疗的情况下就开具了精神药物。
Why is that? You know, when are medications appropriate? Well, there's a complex question. I can say, you know, that every clinician practices within their discipline. So physicians are medical doctors, so the first thing they think of is prescribing a medication. So it's not surprising that that would be frequently used. But we do know, as you mentioned, that psychotherapy is as effective as medications for many of the disorders, mental disorders. And it's more enduring.
这是为什么呢？你知道，药物在什么时候才是合适的？嗯，这是一个复杂的问题。我可以这样说，每个临床医生都在其专业范围内执业。因此，内科医生是医学博士，他们首先想到的就是开药。所以，这种做法被频繁使用也就不足为奇了。但正如你所提到的，我们确实知道，对于许多心理障碍，心理治疗和药物治疗一样有效。而且它的效果更持久。
So when you discontinue medication, some of which have some pretty significant. side effects. People relapse, whereas with psychotherapy, you learn some skills and ways to overcome or accept your difficulties that are longer lasting. Do you find that more people are looking toward psychotherapy because of this very reason, like you mentioned, the side effects, et cetera, and the fact that they're being able to do it more naturally? Well, I think there's a lot of people who really naturally believe in psychotherapy, and that would be their first choice. There's other who are skeptical of psychotherapy and maybe would benefit from other practices, although psychotherapists are really good at working with people even if they're resistant. So I wouldn't say if you don't
因此，当你停药时——其中一些药物具有相当显着的副作用——人们会复发，而通过心理治疗，你可以学到一些技能以及克服或接受困难的方法，这些方法会更持久。你是否发现因为这个原因，有更多的人开始寻求心理治疗？就像你提到的副作用等等，以及他们能够更自然地进行治疗这一事实？嗯，我认为有很多人非常自然地相信心理治疗，这会是他们的首选。还有另一些人对心理治疗持怀疑态度，或许从其他实践中受益，尽管心理治疗师非常擅长与人合作，即使这些人有抵触情绪。所以，我不会说如果你不
believe in psychotherapy is not going to be helpful. That's not really true. But again, so much of it is determined by the person who's treating you. So if you talk about your depression or anxiety with a physician, you're more likely to get medication. That's a kind of a natural consequence, although there's many physicians who recognize the importance of psychotherapy. There are some situations where medication and therapy can work together. There's some research to indicate that the combination is beneficial, but again, it's a case-by-case basis.
相信心理治疗，它就不会有帮助。这并不是真的。但同样，很大程度上这取决于为你治疗的人。因此，如果你向医生倾诉你的抑郁或焦虑，你更有可能会得到药物。这是一种很自然的结果，尽管许多医生也认识到心理治疗的重要性。在某些情况下，药物和治疗可以结合使用。一些研究表明这种组合是有益的，但同样，这也是具体情况具体分析。
And the advantage of dual care like medication and psychotherapy over psychotherapy, over psychotherapy by itself is small. There is a lot of research out there on different kinds of psychotherapies, not just necessarily the therapist, but the therapies themselves, some of which you published and studied. Can we say what makes one type of therapy more effective than another? Well, the research literature really indicates that there isn't one treatment, one kind of psychotherapy that's demonstrably better than any other.
而且，药物加心理治疗这种双重护理相比于单纯的心理治疗，其优势其实很小。关于各种不同的心理治疗，有很多的研究存在——不仅仅是关于治疗师本身，还包括治疗方法本身，其中有一些是你发表和研究过的。我们能说某种类型的治疗比另一种更有效吗？嗯，研究文献确实表明，并没有哪一种治疗方法、哪一种心理治疗明显优于其他方法。
So they all work differently. The activities that are involved in the treatments are different. And what seems to be important is that the patient believes and has faith in this particular method. What works best for them? Some people want a more concrete structured treatment like cognitive behavioral therapy. Other people find more exploratory and interpretive treatments like dynamic treatments. more acceptable. So there's a variety of treatments. There's a variety of people, and it's important to find one that seems to fit for you and works. Where do people research this type of therapy?
所以它们都以不同的方式发挥作用。治疗中涉及的活动是不同的。看似重要的是，患者相信并对这种特定方法有信心。什么对他们最有效？有些人想要更具体、结构化的治疗，比如认知行为疗法。其他人则发现更具探索性和解释性的治疗（如动力学治疗）更容易接受。因此，治疗方法多种多样，人也多种多样，找到一种看似适合你且管用的方法非常重要。人们去哪里研究这种类型的治疗？
I mean, if I'm not sure what I would fit best with, how do people kind of look into the types of therapies that are out there? Well, that's a difficult thing to do because some therapists will advertise this is the kind of therapy I do. Some therapists will wait until they understand the patient's problems and the context before they decide how they're going to work together. But it's really difficult for somebody in the public to say, well, you know, I want brand X. Right. Although, you know, if you want cognitive behavioral therapy, there's organizations which will refer you to cognitive behavioral therapist. same with dynamic therapists and so forth.
我的意思是，如果我不确定自己最适合哪种治疗，人们是如何去了解现有的各种治疗方法的呢？嗯，这是一件很难做到的事情，因为有些治疗师会宣传这是我做的治疗类型。有些治疗师则会等到他们了解了患者的问题和背景后，才决定他们将如何合作。但是，对于公众中的某个人来说，要说“嗯，我想要X品牌”，这其实很难。没错。尽管，你知道，如果你想要认知行为疗法，有一些组织会把你转介给认知行为治疗师。动力学治疗师也是如此，诸如此类。
So that is possible. But again, what I advise people to do is to go to a therapist who is recommended to them and see if this fits, see how it works. Much like a medical doctor, you know, you kind of don't know until you get in their room and see what... That's right. And what's really interesting is that somebody might recommend therapist X because they had a really good experience. and you might not find that style compatible with you at all. Yeah.
所以这是可能的。但再次强调，我建议人们去找一位别人向他们推荐的治疗师，看看这是否合适，看看效果如何。就像找西医一样，你知道，在走进他们的诊室看看到底是怎么回事之前，你其实并不知道……没错。而真正有趣的是，某人可能会推荐X治疗师，因为他们有过非常好的体验，而你可能会发现这种风格与你完全不契合。是的。
Well, thank you, Dr. Wanfold, so much for joining us today. You're welcome. Thanks very much. You can find more information on psychotherapy effectiveness on our website, speakingof psychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嗯，非常感谢万波德博士今天加入我们的节目。不客气，非常感谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 上找到有关心理治疗有效性的更多信息。代表美国心理学会，《心理学热线》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。